[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this ancient
wisdom Money Matters Channel where today
we're diving into topic of Agriculture
trends that the world watches as Farms
transform no longer places of simple
tools and timeworn tradition they are
now hubs of Cutting Edge technology this
is the era of smart agriculture it's a
revolution driven by the need to feed a
growing population we need to produce
more food more efficiently and all while
caring for our planet smart agriculture
power by technology is rising to the
challenge this is not just about better
yields but about a smarter more
sustainable future for farming the
numbers speak for themselves the global
smart agriculture Market is booming
predicted to reach a staggering 33
billion by 2027 farmers are embracing
technology like never before eager to
harness its power from sensors that
monitor soil Health to drones that
survey vast Fields the future of farming
is here
imagine a world where your farm tells
you what it needs even before the first
Leaf wilts that's the promise of the
internet of things or
iot tiny sensors are scattered
throughout the fields like digital eyes
and ears they monitor everything from
soil moisture and temperature to the
amount of sunlight reaching the crops
this constant stream of data is gold to
a farmer with this information a farmer
can make precise informed decisions need
more water in one corner of the field
the sensors will tell you is the soil
lacking vital nutrients the data Reveals
All This targeted approach means less
waste and higher yields water and
fertilizers are used only where needed
saving money and protecting the
[Music]
environment artificial intelligence or
AI is no longer a futuristic fantasy
it's here and it's changing the way we
Farm AI algorithms with their ability to
analyze vast amounts of data are like
digital brains for modern agriculture
they can process information from
sensors drones and even historical
weather patterns to give Farmers a level
of insight never seen before imagine
predicting the weather with Incredible
accuracy weeks in advance AI can do that
helping Farmers plan their planting and
harvesting schedules AI can also detect
diseases in Plants before they're even
visible to the human eye preventing
widespread crop loss this is farming
with a level of precision and foresight
that was once
unimaginable section four taking to the
skies drones and
agriculture drones are no longer just
for aerial photography they've become
essential Tools in modern agriculture
offering a bird's eye view of the farm
equipped with high resolution cameras
and sensors drones can survey vast
fields in a fraction of the time it
would take a farmer on foot this rapid
data collect ction is invaluable need to
assess the health of your crops send in
the drones they can identify areas where
plants are stressed or diseased allowing
for targeted treatment drones can even
apply pesticides and fertilizers with
pinpoint accuracy minimizing waste and
environmental impact this aerial
Revolution is saving Farmers time money
and
resources section five data the new soil
of farming in the digital age data is
the new soil farming it's the foundation
on which smart agriculture thrives all
the technology we've discussed from
sensors to drones generates a treasure
Trove of data but raw data is useless
unless we can understand it that's where
data analytics comes in by crunching
numbers and identifying patterns data
analytics unlocks the secrets hidden
within the data farmers can see Trends
in their yields identify factors
affecting crop health and make
data-driven decisions that optimize
their operations this is precision
agriculture at its finest using data to
make every decision
count section six cultivating a
sustainable future the future of farming
is not just about technology it's about
sustainability as we Face the challenges
of climate change and a growing
population we need to produce food in a
way that protects our planet for
generations to come smart agriculture
with its emphasis on efficiency and
datadriven decisionmaking offers a path
forward regenerative agriculture a
system of farming principles that
focuses on soil health and biodiversity
is gaining traction vertical farming
where crops are grown in vertically
stacked layers offers a way to produce
food in urban areas reducing our
Reliance on traditional farming
practices these Innovations combined
with the power of Technology offer hope
for a future where farming and
sustainability go hand inand if you're
enjoying this video and want to take
your skills to the next level I highly
recommend joining skillshare it's an
amazing platform where you can access
thousands of classes on plus by signing
up through my link below you'll not only
get skills but also directly support my
channel helping me create more content
like this let's learn and grow together
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and turn on notifications you'll
be the first to know when I post new
videos and there's plenty more exciting
stuff on the way